who benefits when people can no longer  vocally say something about this picture  on the right doesn't look right to me  something just looks not quite right who  benefits well maybe the people who are  trying to  get  young children on certain types of  medication and puberty blockers maybe  certain types of woke  you know talking points that need to  penetrate media which is owned by big  pharma you really need to connect the  dots on all of this stuff because when  we talk about the system you know it's  very important conversation you're  talking about um  you know the fda the cdc all of that big  pharma then you're talking about silicon  valley you're talking about big  government you're talking about the  world health organization you're talking  about all of these institutions which  somehow seem to be benefiting from  unhealthy dependent people